maybe i'll play a game now
wait
i'm playing alireza
oh i was challenging him i was i just
sent a funny challenge but now he's now
we're actually playing
ah
does he actually want to oh we're
playing okay i'm playing alireza
what is b3
i'm kind of scared now
this was unexpected
don't hurt me
okay i have hanging pawns
uh
i'm not about to get hurt
okay
so i sack the exchange
man i'm nervous
that's okay though
i got the bishop hair
hmm
i like my position until now
don't hurt me
stop hurting me
trying maybe one
no
still new traps
no i have too many pawns
i may had a i don't know i don't know if
i had chances there
i got too long time though
ah i'm not removing that
let's see his prep here
is he gonna do this funny line what's
the line
ah this line
i was preparing this recently
b3
that's e3
i think it's rook b3
and queen a1
i prepared this after global
championship because i lost
i lost in this as white
queen anyone supposed to be completely
winning
i forgot why
here first
i think this is all my prop
uh let's take
i'm scared he's going to trick me
but this is completely winning for white
now it's even more winning
uh
let's not freak out
check
don't trick me
i'm also queen in so many ponds for a
rook
don't mess with my pawns
my hands are shaking
palms are sweaty you're playing ally
right good luck
let's go okay it's one to one
that means we're equal strength right
i want to play stafford
what is this
don't hurt me
my my watch is charging right now but
maybe after this game i'll put on the
heart rate monitor
heart rate is very high right now
and take this
now i have to move
[Music]
here i mean the last game he played like
a a dubious opening
thinking that he could
crush me with it
but i was prepared like
15 moves deep so
it worked out
is he gonna meet me no
maybe
oh no
i have to play this move
um
this isn't good
doh he's mating me okay well played
or wait is he mating me
yeah ouch
i always play bishop takes off h
checkmates
okay no more england
is he gonna play this no okay
let's play one of these
uh bishop d2
okay
i want to buy knight
d5 get the bishop here
not a five
yeah
not pretty but it's playable
e5 first
let's not hang a queen
i sack again
sacking for the attack
it's interesting
i want to play f6
it takes me to this
uh
oh no my knight
where's my win
g5 is coming
yeah
i thought it was being tricky
ah
probably should not have done that
[Music]
stop it
stop it
ah
twice the bishop was hanging and he
didn't take it because it would have
been stalemate i thought it was being so
clever there
savage amba time no
what is this
oh it's a eurosov gambit knight of three
prepared this for candy
magmans
no this is this is main line
i haven't looked at this in a while
though
i think queen takes this main line
bishop d7
i'm pretty sure this is still prep
here
oh no
wait a minute
good luck duck him rose and duck thanks
i'm gonna need it
how bad is this both knights are hanging
but i'm down a thing
wow that's a good move
yeah i'm down the exchange
down a little bit of time too
gotta believe
wow
yeah that's not good
or is it
[Music]
turning almost something but not quite
is this a draw
no it's not
oh there's some table-based draw but i
think the pawn has to be on the sixth
rank
i need a different color bishop
please remove no ah
i was hoping he pre-moved queen a5
what am i doing
this looks playable
i lost a pawn
it still looks playable though
[Music]
get a pawn to c7
[Music]
e5 coming
don't play e5
ah
this move
ah
wow
i'm so baffled
how do i not lose
to play this
that's sad
i tried a dirty trick
no
ah
oh that's rough
okay
okay
stafford gambit against fruija
ooh stafford grant declined
a sign of fear maybe
it's already like slightly better for
black i
think i've looked at this line at some
point
uh probably this
hmm
i'm down two pawns
what do you do to me
uh i wanna do things but they don't work
this
let's move first
stop it
soccer rook
okay
some threat maybe
ah
okay
i don't think this works at all
[Music]
where'd all my time go
okay i resigned that was rough
i think i was slightly why mouse left
i'm so tilted now okay king's indian
time
to play like akaru
oh it's a reverse dragon actually
okay
i think this is reasonable
so it's six to one overall
[Music]
i hope the layout's okay
oh fancy move
f4 maybe this move
he wants to play queen here but i have
f3
que pasa
[Music]
what
maybe i'm okay
i'm down so much time though
no
ah
one move away
okay i resign my flag what a funny game
okay we have vienna
this is some opening i'm slightly
prepared in
uh i think bishop bishop c5 bishop b4
okay
i mean it's scary
i think i'll have to sack
this move
i'm still gonna have to attack after
queen h3
this is rough
it takes takes
it's a fork but it does not really a
meaningful fork
yeah i got counterfort
ah rough game okay
go back to my bread and butter
okay
queen b2 i can force a draw
okay this line i don't mind
this is known to be like slightly better
for white
i can't celebrate too early always a
good time with eric rosen oh thank you
kind person
do you lafayette
[Music]
play this
it's a good time until i run out of time
wow
okay
wow
i'm just missing moves
he wants to meet me
i'm finding this
what
[Music]
wow
ah i was trying to set it up oh
gg
okay
play this
staff organic time
[Music]
uh let's play let's play this one
[Music]
uh take take
uh he knows tactics
he really knows tactics
how bad is this
i think it's pretty bad
uh
or is it
i have no time though
stop hurting me
is it meeting
it is oh no
[Music]
i got needed oh
i got greek gifted
[Music]
okay i'm not yet adopted
is this adoption game though
okay
let's crank it up a notch
um
stop hurting me
oh man i'm close to a pawn cube
this is okay
why is my queen there
why is my queen so sad
i got forked
okay steal me time
dough
dough
ah good game
ggs
thanks
oh i have a new father